(crowd cheering)
- [Announcer] And it's a good shot.
- We found something in our reporting,
something happening here in
the one big city in Qatar,
a place the whole world
is looking at right now,
(dramatic music)
an invisible border drawn
to trap human beings,
to make them work, to make them build.
I wanna show this to you.
So, let me take you back
to show you how we ended up
sending a camera to someone
and teaching them how to
shoot undercover in Qatar
while simultaneously capturing
interviews in rural Nepal
and how I ended up here staring for hours
at maps drawn by the Qatari government,
all of this to shine a light on something
that Qatar doesn't want the world to see.
- [Raj] All of these have
been emptied very recently.
(fingers tapping)
(mouse clicking)
- Hey, I need to show you something.
I've been looking at maps of Qatar
because the World Cup is going there.
When the world is gonna
be fixated on one place,
you gotta look at all the maps.
I've been on the
government website of Qatar
looking at their zoning maps.
This is the city of Doha,
the capital of Qatar,
but look at this.
The whole city is yellow,
and there's this one little shape of blue,
Doha Industrial Area.
I know we're talking about zoning.
I think something's up here.
I've been trying to map this, like,
throw it on, like, my
other tools to map it
and see if there's,
like, what this could be,
and it's not totally making sense.
It's kind of cut off from
the rest of the city.
There's another municipality
kind of in between it and Doha,
but it's a part of Doha.
Usually, when you have
weird zoning like this,
there's something going on.
Since Qatar got awarded
the World Cup in 2010,
there's been all sorts of issues
with their labor
conditions and all of that,
and I think this has to do with that,
but I don't totally know.
The World Cup is happening in a few weeks.
I wanna go to this place.
(camera clicking)
I need to reach out to Cammy,
one of our research producers.
We're gonna dive into this.
We're gonna figure it out.
We're going to Doha, folks.
Hey Cammy, I wanna go to
Qatar before the World Cup
to look at this one part of the city
that's completely zoned differently.
I think it has to do with,
like, the labor situation there.
(printer beeping)
I can't not print it.
(paper rustling)
All right, I'm going there.
We have to find a fixer, a local producer,
someone on the ground who
can help us not get arrested.
I will follow up tomorrow
with more details.
Doo, doo, doo, doo, doo, doo, doo.
- Hey.
- Going to Qatar.
♪ Doong, doong, doong, doong,
doong, doong, doong, doong ♪
- Johnny, yes, let's do it.
This sounds like a really great story,
and I'll happily go to Doha with you.
I'll start researching right now.
- I'm going to Qatar.
- Congratulations.
I just want you to be smart.
- I've been doing some
research, and I don't know
how easy it's gonna be
for us to film places,
especially in the Industrial Area.
From what I've read, they're notoriously
not very kind to journalists.
- The best part about the
Gulf is that these cities are,
like, so, like, cartoonish.
This is a hotel in freaking Doha.
Look at this.
Opening later this year.
Can I stay in this hotel
that looks like a freaking half pipe?
I've always wanted to do this.
I've never had an excuse.
(energetic music)
- Doha fixer number one
referred me to someone else,
so fingers crossed
that Doha fixer number
two is gonna work out.
- Drones, yes.
Do you think they'll let
me fly my drone in Doha?
- No.
- [Johnny] Why?
- NATO countries are helping
out doing anti-drone stuff
'cause they're afraid of, you know,
terrorist drones coming in so that, like-
- [Johnny] Wait, but what
about just my DJI drone?
- They're sending out anti-drones-
- [Johnny] Geez.
- to net them.
(camera clicking)
- [Johnny] Wait, what?
- Yeah, oh, lemme show you.
- Okay, not great news, our
fixer hasn't found anybody
in the Industrial Area
who wants to talk with us.
It's not looking likely that
they're going to find anybody.
I'm gonna keep trying to connect
with anyone on the ground.
- I think it's a hiding people thing.
I don't know, but I'm
trying to find a fixer
to help me get in there.
- You're gonna go in there?
- Yes.
I mean it's just, it's not,
like, some secret part-
- You're supposed to be leaving in a week,
and we haven't found any fixers.
We haven't found any people on
the ground who could help us.
I'm just a bit concerned
of our timeline right now.
(pensive music)
- I think we found someone, a fixer
who is deeply connected with
the worker population in Doha
and is potentially gonna help us
to get into the Industrial Area.
We're meeting with him
on a call in a few minutes.
(app ringing)
Here we go.
Nice to meet you.
How are you doing?
- [Fixer] Fine, let's switch off the A/C.
- Did you get the proposal that
we sent over of what we're-
- [Fixer] Yeah, proposal, I read.
- We're not trying to get
any secretive footage.
It's more just about life
in the Industrial Area.
I guess my question for you is, like,
if I went into the Industrial
Area with my camera,
not a big crew but just
my camera to go film-
- [Fixer] What camera?
- Like this.
If I went into the Industrial
Area with this camera-
- [Fixer] No, no, no.
- and filmed
- [Fixer] No.
Another thing, your skin color
is also a problem, you know?
- Ah, explain that.
What do you mean?
- [Fixer] Yeah, it will make, you know,
you will get undue attention.
- From who do you think I
would get undue attention?
- [Fixer] You know, of course,
the informers, and you know,
these Industrial Area
Asian towns are controlled
by internal security
forces, Al-Fazaa police.
- So, it's not very smart for me
to go filming around in that area?
- [Fixer] Yeah.
- Okay, and I think that's why
we want to figure out a way.
- [Fixer] Have you ever
been to Doha, I mean-
- [Johnny] No.
- in Qatar?
- It's my first time.
(fixer clears throat)
What do you think?
(dramatic music)
- Okay.
This is not happening,
this is not happening.
If we can't do the shots,
then this story doesn't work,
meaning I won't go to Doha.
So, it's pretty important
for us to know soon
if this is feasible or
if it's not feasible.
Iz, can you-
- [Fixer] Yeah, yeah, I
understand, I understand.
- Well, it's really nice to meet you.
Thank you so much for chatting.
I can't safely go into
this Industrial Area.
Like, it's now clear to me, like,
every fixer has just been like, "No."
This guy just said it point blank.
He's like, "You're a
white dude with a camera.
Like, this is not safe."
- It feels like, if you go,
you're just gonna, what,
get shots of shiny buildings
and not actually gain access.
- Yeah.
- Which I guess could be cool.
- No.
- I mean, there's an option here
where you try to find someone
that could go in.
- And then, if we could
get, like, a camera person
in Nepal, or Bangladesh, or somewhere
where workers have been and gone home,
we could totally tell this story.
The World Cup is literally
a few weeks away.
I got some work to do.
The new plan, find someone
on the ground in Qatar
who will go
into the Industrial Area
(paper rustling)
and tell me why the hell the government is
so afraid of me going in with my camera.
(paper rustling)
(mouse clicking)
Okay (sighs).
Okay, before we continue,
I need to tell you about something,
which is that today's video
is not sponsored by any brand.
Sometimes we do really deep dives
into complicated and sensitive topics.
It's hard to find a sponsor
when we make stories like this.
I wanna tell you about a way
that you can support what we're doing.
If you're not interested in
hearing this pitch from me,
that's totally fine.
So, I'm gonna put a little bar
down here on the bottom of the screen.
For the rest of you that
are still here, thank you,
and I wanna tell you about The Newsroom.
The Newsroom is our community on Patreon,
which is more and more
turning into a place
that I am very excited about.
Journalism is changing,
and I'm making big bets
that the type of journalism
that will succeed
in the future is the type of journalism
that dives deep without the need
for a journalistic institution to dictate
what direction we need to go.
I want the story to guide
me whatever way it takes me.
And I'm allowed to do that
because I'm here on
YouTube with all of you.
But doing this form of
journalism on YouTube is
incredibly resource intensive.
Behind the scenes, we have
a lot of people making sure
that we're factually accurate,
that we are actually finding
the best facts possible.
It's hard and resource intensive,
but I'm gonna keep doing it.
That's where you all come in.
For those who are supporting
over at The Newsroom,
you allow us to do this
kind of journalism.
But if that's not enough for you,
we also have some really cool perks,
including an extra video every month.
We do a behind-the-scenes
video every month,
where we show you everything
that is happening,
all of the people, and
personalities, and processes
that make this stuff happen.
There are a lot of really
fun, talented people
making this work possible.
You also get access to one
of my scripts every month,
and you get access to some
exclusive Tom Fox tracks.
Tom is our composer.
He makes amazing music.
We will give you some of
that music, royalty free,
for you to use however you'd like.
And we'll ask the community to vote
on thumbnails, and
titles, and video ideas.
And I really value having a
smaller version of this group
here on YouTube but, like,
over on The Newsroom.
If you're not able to
support, that's totally fine.
I appreciate you being
here in the first place.
At the end of the day, being
here, watching the videos,
sharing them is a huge way
that this community allows me
to do what I can do to
make better journalism.
So, that's my little pitch to you
for those interested
and willing to support.
I want to get back into this story
and show you how we ended
up in this situation.
(resolute music)
Qatar is a tiny, super-rich
country in the desert,
and it sits on the largest known
natural gas field on Earth.
(liquid sloshing)
Since their independence in 1970,
Qatar got really rich, really fast,
leapfrogging the normal
economic development process
that countries go through as they grow.
Usually, as a country gets rich,
immigrants from poorer
neighboring countries migrate
in to take lower paying jobs
(machines buzzing)
required to keep the economy growing,
construction, hospitality,
manual labor, care-taking, food services,
you know what I mean.
Every rich country experiences this,
but in Qatar,
(inquisitive music)
all of their neighbors were also getting
super rich super fast,
so they started looking
elsewhere for cheap
labor, and soon, there was
a flow of people taking these jobs.
But there's a tension here.
Thanks to all this
abundant oil and gas money,
the Qatari government provides
a luxurious welfare state
to their citizens, free
healthcare, education,
guaranteed jobs, subsidized housing,
and literally, they just get
paychecks for being Qatari,
for winning the fossil-fuel jackpot.
So, Qatar needed labor
from other countries,
but they didn't wanna let these immigrants
in on the sumptuous benefits
of their welfare state.
So, they started using this system,
where employers could sponsor workers
to come to Qatar to work.
They wouldn't be citizens
or anything close to it.
They would be totally at
the mercy of their employer.
This was called the kafala system,
and it was the foundation
upon which Qatar built its country.
(inquisitive music continues)
- The winner to organize
the 2022 FIFA World Cup is Qatar.
(energetic music)
(audience cheering)
- So, this is a giant moment.
It's oof.
I mean, I made a whole video
about how this happened.
I'm not gonna go into it,
but the fact is that, as soon
as Qatar won the World Cup-
- Thank you, FIFA.
- they had a lotta work to do
because their country didn't
have a lot of infrastructure,
basically any infrastructure
at all, to host this thing.
So, wait, why were they
chosen to host the World Cup
if they didn't have any infrastructure?
It's a long story.
Again, I made an entire video about it.
The fact is they needed to build
a bunch of stuff in a very short time.
So, what they basically did
is just ramp up the system
that they already had,
importing tons of labor
from South Asia and Africa
to come build their country,
in this case, to build
infrastructure for the World Cup.
(energetic music continues)
So, yeah, I've been deep in
the context, and the history,
and the data for all of this,
the stuff I can do from the office,
but the fact is time is running out.
(active music)
I need to find
someone on the ground, someone in Doha,
someone in Bangladesh or
Nepal who can help me capture
what is actually
happening in these places,
talk to the people there.
I've been planting lots of seeds,
and some of them are starting to sprout,
so we're getting closer.
We're getting closer.
(mouse clicking)
(inquisitive music)
- Hey, I've been talking
with a journalist in Nepal
who's really great and can
connect us with workers
who've returned home.
He's done a lot of work on this,
and he can go out and
shoot these interviews.
(inquisitive music continues)
- I'm finally just settling into the fact
that I'm not going to Doha,
and I'm disappointed in that
because I wanted to be on the ground.
I wanted to see this issue,
but the right choice is
to use those resources
to engage camera people
to go capture the right stories
in different parts of the world,
and that's what we're gonna do.
Luckily, I've got Instagram.
(upbeat music)
I also have miso soup.
(Johnny slurping)
Hey, Sandra, thanks so
much for reaching out.
I really appreciate it.
I'm doing this deep dive on the World Cup.
Put a call out for people
in Doha to help me out here.
I was gonna be going to Qatar,
and I was gonna be there
next week, but I'm not going.
I'm now looking for people
on the ground to help me,
and as always, a bunch
of people responded.
I live in a world where I
can just ask for things,
and there's such a supportive community
who wants to help with these stories,
which is just an amazing reality.
Probably 15 to 20 hours
over the next two weeks
getting some shots.
Can I officially, you know, hire you
as a contractor to do this?
And again, all of this is 100% anonymous.
We will make sure that everyone is safe.
(lips fluttering)
(inquisitive music continues)
Bingo, yes, yes, yes.
I am talking to somebody in
Qatar who is a journalist
who wants to help me out and is excited.
Oh, my god, I feel so much better.
There is someone in Doha
who has camera skills,
there we go, who has language skills,
who has journalism skills,
who's excited to help
and is just ready to go.
Oh, my gosh, nice to meet you (laughs).
- [Raj] Hello.
- How you doing?
- [Raj] Yeah, everything's great.
- Really appreciate you just, like,
harnessing the energy on this
and just being super down.
And they have access
to the Industrial Area.
Yes.
I want you to tell me
how comfortable you feel
about this process in terms
of safety and security,
what's sensitive, what's not.
Just gimme an overview of
where some red lines are here.
I found someone in Doha
who I could give a camera to to film.
We're gonna call him Raj.
We won't be showing his face.
We'll change his voice
because he could get in
deep trouble for this.
- [Raj] First things first,
everything is monitored,
or, like, surveillance works
everywhere in this country.
No matter where I film,
I'm also being filmed.
Specifically, if you come
to the Industrial Area,
there are a few layers to what we can do
and what we cannot do.
- [Johnny] And over the next several weeks
of talking to Raj, I
realized that my fixation
on this one blue square isn't
actually the full story.
It's just the beginning.
- [Raj] I plan to go on every street
and film from inside the car,
and I think that's the safest way to film
and get, like, the vibe of what is it like
to get inside the city.
(ice cubes clinking)
(Johnny exhaling)
(glass thudding)
- We have someone on the ground
with a camera that we bought them.
I've lined them out on
how to shoot undercover.
- [Raj] I actually
wanted to ask you, like,
how do you get along shooting footages
without getting noticed?
- The key to filming without being seen is
to look elsewhere.
You're holding this thing
like you're holding a an ice cream cone.
- [Raj] Yeah.
- You're walking around,
and you're looking elsewhere,
and then you just smoothly,
you know, put it away,
and you just get really comfortable
with turning it on and off.
They're going to the Industrial Area.
They are very, very cautious
for a very good reason.
I would like you to shoot
in 60 frames a second.
I'd like you to shoot in 4K.
This is gonna be an amazing
story if we can pull it off.
'Kay, goodbye.
- Talk to you soon.
- The government of Qatar is
way more insane than I
expected, and we're gonna take
a lot of precautions
to keep everyone safe.
We're gonna show the world
what Qatar doesn't want the world to see.
(tense music)
- [Raj] So, I'm an Uber
because, frankly, it's
very unsafe to go on a bus.
This is the bus stop where you get
on a bus to the Industrial Area.
How much time does it
take for you to get here?
It should be like one
and a half hour, right?
- Raj was finally heading
to the Industrial Area
to show us exactly what this place was.
But it wasn't until we
heard from the people
who had worked there and lived there
that we began to see how
deep this trap really was.
Today is the day.
In Nepal, a million miles away,
they have been shooting interviews.
Look, these are people who actually worked
on the World Cup stadiums and
are now back home in Nepal.
You start to get to the human side of it,
and it becomes way less theoretical.
It's way less about these
zoning maps and stuff,
and it becomes about real humans,
and this where it starts to get heavy.
(dramatic music)
(Goma speaking in foreign language)
(footsteps plodding)
(Bikram speaking in foreign language)
(dramatic music continues)
(Sushil speaking in foreign language)
(child speaking in foreign language)
- As we've been setting
up all these logistics
and figuring all of this out,
(mouse clicking)
we've also been reporting
and investigating
the bigger context here.
The Industrial Area,
this little blue shape
on the map is
(paper rustling)
actually just one of several mechanisms
that the Qatari government
uses to bring people
over to their country to trap them there
and then to exploit them to work to build
all the things they want them to build.
(paper rustling)
(pensive music)
Lemme show you.
Okay, so it's 2010.
Qatar just won the World Cup bid.
They have to build an unfathomable
amount of infrastructure
in a very short time.
They do this by paying a bunch of people
to go to these countries,
to small villages
in places like Bangladesh and Nepal
to recruit a bunch of workers
to come to Qatar to build.
And this is the first phase
of what I'm calling the Qatar trap
because it is here where
these workers were told
they had to pay a recruitment fee,
usually like one to $4,000
just to, like, get recruited
to go to Qatar and work.
These people don't have
one to $4,000 lying around.
So, they often would
borrow money from family
or take out a loan with
really high interest rates.
So, even before they start working,
they start their relationship
with work in Qatar with debt.
So, now you have workers from
Bangladesh, India, Nepal,
all over this region flooding
into Qatar to start building.
As this is happening,
Qatar implements a law.
(dramatic music)
This is a law that's
meant to protect families.
Okay.
The law says that worker
groups are not allowed
to live within, quote, "family
areas" in the city of Doha.
It's a little ambiguous.
Well, the government later clarified
that what they're
referring to is bachelors,
people in Qatar that are single men.
Okay, so these bachelors
can't live in family zones.
Where are these family zones
that bachelors can't live in?
Is it just like one
little part of the city?
(inquisitive music)
No.
To clarify, they released
a map that looks like this.
Everything in yellow is a family zone,
a place where bachelor workers
are not allowed to live.
If you project it onto, like, a real map,
you will see that this is
the entire city, basically.
And then, they reserved one
little plot of land a city away,
still zoned for Doha,
this little blue shape,
where these bachelor workers can live.
Oh, but they made a few exceptions.
Anyone who works at, like,
markets, and barber shops,
restaurants, oh, and
white collar professionals
who are bachelors can also
stay in the family zones.
So, really these working
bachelors is just a euphemism
for guys who look like this,
guys who are there doing construction
who Qatar does not want to see
in their shiny downtown area.
So, they reserved them a spot out here
in the desert next to the sewage pond.
This is the map that sent
me down the rabbit hole,
and now I see it for what it is.
I knew something was up.
I looked at a bunch of these
(censored) zoning maps.
They're using this to put the people
that they don't wanna see in the places
that will never be seen.
So, now these guys are
already laden with debt
because of the recruiting fees,
and now they're relegated and trapped
into this part of the
city, the part of the city
that I was not allowed to go
to without getting arrested.
This is where Raj is on his way to.
This is where we're getting footage from.
(tense music)
- [Raj] 50 minutes into the ride,
and we're kind of starting to see
these kind of accommodations
where the workers live.
This is one of those
buses that the workers
that live in the Industrial
Area use to commute.
Today is Friday, and it's a leisure day
for a lot of workers, as
you can see a lot of clothes
that have been washed and
left in the sun to be dried.
- So, this is the Industrial Area.
It's the thing I've been thinking
about for a very long time,
and I'm finally seeing
the footage from inside,
and I have to say, it's not
anything super surprising.
This is kind of anti-climatic in the sense
that I'm just looking
at like a kind of dusty,
dilapidated part of town
with a bunch of buildings
that look the same, and
yet, I now know a lot more
about what this place represents.
Look at this.
The Industrial Area isn't just far away.
It's completely cut off.
Here's the metro system, brand new,
that they were planning to
build for the World Cup.
This is a whole system,
connects all of the stadiums and the city.
You can see that they planned
a couple of these lines
to go out to the Industrial Area.
This would connect the
Industrial Area to the city,
and yet, these (laughing)
lines aren't actually built.
They're gonna start on these
right after the World Cup is over.
So, yeah, this place is just,
like, completely disconnected.
I think I now see that,
and it's not just
disconnected unintentionally.
This is very systematically,
intentionally disconnected
from the rest of the city.
Our interviews in Nepal
gave us some clarity
on what it's like to live out there.
(mouse clicking)
(Sushil speaking in foreign language)
- The next phase of the
Qatar trap has to do
with how these people were exploited,
how their rights were taken away from them
to force them to work.
(pensive music)
To build the World Cup,
these workers were forced
to work in very horrible conditions.
Look at the temperatures
in Doha in the summer,
getting close to 50 degrees Celsius,
close to 120 degrees Fahrenheit.
They literally have
air-conditioned outdoor spaces.
Look at that, air conditioning
outside on wheels.
The stadiums themselves
will have air conditioning.
And yet, these workers are out there
doing, like, manual labor in this heat.
(Bikram speaking in foreign language)
- A lot of workers report
being treated like animals,
being yelled at and bossed
around in totally inhumane ways.
(Bikram speaking in foreign language)
- Behind these walls, the conditions
that these people were made to live in
and really given no choice
on where they could live are horrendous.
(Bikram speaking in foreign language)
(Sushil speaking in foreign language)
- Journalists and human
rights organizations have
actually gotten cameras
back here to actually show
what that looks like.
The heat and conditions
got so bad for some workers
that they never returned home.
(Goma speaking in foreign language)
(dramatic music)
(camera clicking)
(Goma speaking in foreign language)
- Thousands of totally
healthy young men died
while working in these conditions.
(inquisitive music)
We'll likely never know
the true cause of death
because instead of a real investigation,
the Qatari authorities come out and use
these vague classifications
like heart failure
and natural causes as the cause of death.
Doing this robs the family of answers
on why their loved one came home in a box.
(Goma speaking in foreign language)
(gentle music)
- So, if these employers are so bad,
why don't these employees
just change jobs?
The answer is they can't.
(pensive music)
For a long time, legally,
they couldn't because the next part
of this trap has to do with paperwork.
(Sushil speaking in foreign language)
- Oftentimes this
paperwork would stipulate
that these workers can't change jobs
without the permission of their employers.
So, the status of these
workers who were trapped
in their little blue box on
the outskirts of the city was
completely at the mercy
of their employers.
If they left their job,
they would be considered
a foreign immigrant illegally there
and could be arrested and put into jail.
(Sushil speaking in foreign language)
- Just one more layer of the trap.
And then, there was the fact
that these employers would
often not pay their workers
for months at a time
withholding wages from them
and thus increasing their
leverage and power over them.
And with no recourse,
these workers couldn't
do anything about it.
So, yes, we are now talking
about forced labor with no compensation,
a euphemism for modern-day slavery.
I know that sounds dramatic,
but that's literally
what is happening here,
not to all workers.
There were workers who
had great conditions
and who got paid on time,
but this system enabled firms
to so deeply exploit workers
because it gave them
so much power over them
and so little recourse for these workers
to complain or do anything
without being punished or arrested.
So, with with no other options,
some workers turned to their
last resort, protesting.
(dramatic music)
(protestors speaking in foreign language)
(Sushil speaking in foreign language)
- Here they are blocking
traffic, central Doha.
(mouse clicking)
But don't be fooled here.
This wasn't some worker uprising.
This type of thing is illegal in Qatar,
an authoritarian police state
where assembly like this
is totally not okay.
So, what happened is the
police would show up,
squash these protests, tell them
that everything was gonna be okay
and they would get paid and then deported
a huge number of these people,
got them outta the system
so that the status quo could remain.
- [Raj] Just dehumanizing
people that belong
to a certain race and are brought here
for certain purposes is
not justified by any means.
- Thanks to international scrutiny,
Qatar started to make some reforms.
They realized this wasn't gonna fly
if they were gonna host the World Cup.
So, they started instituting
things like worker hours
that were not in the heat of the day,
mandatory water on site so these
people could stay hydrated,
a minimum wage, changing the law
so that people could
technically change jobs
without permission, compensating families
for people who died working.
All of this looked great on paper,
but human rights organizations
like Amnesty International
actually have looked to see
if those policies have
trickled into reality.
And you know what I'm gonna say.
They haven't.
(pensive music)
- [Raj] This is the Shahaniya labor camp.
This is big walls.
A lot of people live here as well.
(pensive music continues)
- So, yeah, I really understand now
what this little blue box
is for, what it represents.
The authorities in Doha are getting ready
for this World Cup, and
as the event approaches,
they are making sure
that anyone who belongs
in this box stays in that box.
(dramatic music)
Okay, this is insane,
the timing of this.
This is literally happening right now.
- [Raj] The whole thing
has just been wiped out
by some weird phenomenon.
- I just got a message from Raj
that they are evicting
workers from the city.
People who are living
(paper rustling)
in the yellow area illegally
because of the law are being evicted.
It's a couple weeks before the World Cup,
and so the timing is not surprising
that they are cracking down.
(paper rustling)
- [Raj] Locks everywhere,
everything looks like it
has been done really quick.
They are literally catching people
and putting them into Shahaniya,
which is the Industrial Area.
I'm trying to get footages
of them being evicted
because a lot of them are being evicted,
like, just with two hours of notice.
That's what I'm trying to do now.
- This is so clear to me what's happening.
They're clearly starting to really enforce
this, like, family zoning
thing to get anyone
who they don't want to be seen
out of the center of the city.
I've never done a story
(laughs) like this before.
This is developing, like, day by day,
and all of this reporting that we've done,
I'm now seeing it play out in real time
as the city prepares for the World Cup,
using all of these laws to
continue to hide these people,
to get them out of view
as all of these international
visitors prepare to come.
- [Raj] It feels so empty,
and it's only the small houses
that have been evacuated.
(inquisitive music)
- [Announcer] Strike, against the post.
(papers rustling)
(mouse clicking)
- Okay, well we got to the bottom of it.
(papers rustling)
We know what know why this
exists, the way it's drawn,
what it means,
(papers thudding)
who it's for, what it's meant to do.
(headset thudding)
I did not expect that.
I know what's happening
behind those walls,
how those people are trapped,
how their families miss them,
and how some of them
might never come home.
(Goma speaking in foreign language)
- Now, let's be clear, this happened
well before the World
Cup ever came to Qatar.
And what I fear is that,
once we all move on,
once these few weeks of
playing football are over,
we'll forget about everything we saw,
and Qatar will have no incentive
to actually do anything about this.
And they'll go back to what
they've been doing for decades,
deceiving these workers,
trapping them in their country,
exploiting them, and then
hiding them from view.
(papers rustling)
(inquisitive music)
(inquisitive music continues)